I'm not nervous I don't live here so uh
Jennifer you've made me laugh so [ __ ]
much I just like god dammit thank you
for getting knocked up and you're
beautiful and thank you for recommending
my clips and uh I love Ellie being like
thank you for like loving real people
and she's like a [ __ ] supermodel um
like the little uglies it's like you
found us I am I'm probably like 160
pounds right now and I can catch a dick
whenever I want like that's the truth
it's not a problem it's not a problem
you said we could take our time right
and I don't have any um somebody on the
red carpet was like do you feel like out
of place and I'm like no of course not
I'm look at like I'm very glamorous uh I
I didn't lose my two front teeth until I
was in fifth grade which is late and
that very same week I got my period
which is early so I was just like this
jack-o'-lantern with tits walking around
just like ah like trick-or-treat and uh
and I had one of those moms it was like
you don't need to shave above your knee
so just a werewolf just Christopher
Robin just here down and and uh and and
glamour thank you so much Joe glamour
has been so nice to me just any any
comic in the room knows that when a
female comic has a photo shoot they're
like oh cool like can you hold this like
plastic dick over your head and we're
gonna like shoot um like actual come out
of it onto your head and you're like oh
thank you yes and uh right they're just
like oh you're gonna be like a calm down
starting you're like oh thank you for
having me but uh glamour you're the
pizza they're the first magazine that
was like smile then I was like where's a
dick and they're like no just be you and
glamour has given me a lot its glamour
has given me a voice you know joke I the
first time I I told this story about Mia
going home with a guy on freshman year
college and like think well going home
with him is being like very kind I
thought
I thought he was calling me like in
during the day to hang out but then it
turned out that he had been out all
night and he was in a blackout and I
told that story just about like losing
yourself a steam and then just like
finding and being like no I'm not going
to apologize for who I am and I'm going
to actually love the skin that I'm in
and not be like striving for some other
version of myself and yeah and I and I
make fun of women's magazines a lot
because they're just great fodder and
you know some of them make you feel bad
for just being born with a [ __ ] they're
just like they're like got your [ __ ]
that new-car smell
and you're like what a pinecone from
your clinic ok um like right some of the
guys are not even remotely smiling and
you know what I don't live here I don't
care tonight I had one goal and that was
to just be able to take my underwear off
at the end of the night and have it not
look like I blew my nose in it and
and don't look disgusting guys cuz
you're under it looks like a coal miner
wipe their brow at the end of a shift
anyway I'm so grateful to be here I've
never been here before
our family vacations were like to
Tijuana and I want to thank Joe I want
to thank glamor I want to thank my
publicist who left oh hey I'm like makes
sense
I can't believe it hasn't happened yet
and my my my younger sister Kim who we
do everything together and we made this
movie and it's all about any secrets
I've left and a man I want to really
thank Goldie Hawn who I just have loved
and it's made me laugh so much and be
that beautiful and vulnerable and
hilarious and a boss it just it's been
so inspiring um yeah I feel like I
burned all the bridges possible alright
thank you so much thank you